you got to be so pumped and everybody at
home has been pumped during this
pandemic because they've had some great
entertainment with cobra kai because
it has been at the top of netflix's
streaming charts
so how does it feel to have fresh set of
eyes new audience there
that you're able to discover during
these times
it's awesome you know it's i love this
opportunity of being a part of
you know the karate kid universe and the
part of a show that you know so many
people love around the world
and it's it's it's really cool going
from youtube to netflix and seeing the
spike and
uh you know everyone talking about the
show it's awesome i
couldn't ask for anything else yeah i
think it's a little scary
you know the show already felt big when
we were on youtube and it felt like we
had kind of found our home and
and figured you know the show was going
to be as big as it was going to get and
then the move to netflix
really blew it out of proportion i was
we i don't think anyone could have
expected the the great turnout that we
found and i think a lot of it is
due to the pandemic i think a lot of it
is due to people
not really realizing that the show
existed i think
you know there's there's this kind of
perfect storm that that
came together at the right time i'm
still a little scared but
ready to uh to move on to the next
chapter something else that's
mind-blowing i'm so
sure that you guys are wildly excited
about this
season three hasn't even come out yet
you've already been renewed for season
four
yes so what kind of scripts are you
seeing these days have you said
they know better than to give the two
teenagers yeah they would
never touch us with any sort of like
pivotal information
at all like that would that that would
not happen we get out there and they do
a puppet show replication of what's
gonna happen during the season and
that's it they don't show us any scripts
now you guys have some intense fighting
scenes in season three
i thought one two i thought they were
intense
season three y'all picking it up a notch
so what does the training
look like for some of those epic scenes
especially the one
in episode 10. it's like a dog right
damn yeah the training a lot of the
training honestly is stretching
so much of it is stretching and you know
we'll sit on a wall and put our legs up
and they'll come
you know the sudden tornadoes come by
and just stretch your legs out because
you got to kick someone in the face you
got to be able to get your leg up there
and a lot of it is you know working
through the choreography and making sure
that everyone has it down especially for
a fight like the episode 10 fight where
there's
a ton of moving pieces you know everyone
has to be as dialed in as they can
there's a lot of crazy stuff that
happens in that
episode 10 fight that i'm really excited
for people to watch
the final cut is definitely super dope
to
see and i guess being there on the day
was shot it was it's
crazy to think and and also it was
filmed so long ago like over a year ago
it's crazy to see it all now and be like
oh
wow perfect it's exactly how we kind of
imagined it so
so i i know that you know hito and
janelle our stunt coordinators are super
proud of it and
you know as we move on to these next
seasons you know hopefully you know
we have season four coming up obviously
and and hopefully more seasons after
that but
but i know that if we stay with hito and
janelle the
the bar is just going to get topped each
and each time without a doubt now
we saw your character miguel i mean
season two left us with quite a
cliffhanger
with him so how are miguel's injuries
going to affect him
in season three i mean the most obvious
one
at face value is that it's going to be
hard for him to walk again
or really use his legs at all um
and but i think more so than that
really is going to be this mental
barrier between
him and johnny i'm always gonna be right
here next to you
because i'll always be your teacher
oh [ __ ] that's all right you felt like a
champ
i think the two of them although they're
so like-minded
have a lot of you know working to do
with themselves before they can
reconcile again and i think
obviously you know miguel's mom is going
to
be another big uh hurdle between the two
of them
being that she loves johnny and and
and she really has a lot of care for him
but also
you know without him there would be no
problems with her son so i think it's
going to be that
that inner battle between the whole kind
of little triangle but
as a fan of the show and as someone who
you know
loves johnny i want nothing more than
him and miguel to
to be together again okay i gotta ask
johnny and daniel may or may not be
coming to a truce's season and actually
you know being on the same page after 35
years
when you read how this could be playing
out this season
what were your thoughts guys i was uh
i'm just as anxious as everybody you
know i think
i think the idea of them coming together
is awesome
i don't know like in practice how
successful they're gonna be because
they're very much
they've been at odds with each other you
know for the last 30 something years so
it'll definitely be interesting to see
you know if when that happens
but i'm all for it you know you're all
for it oh yeah
what about you mr miguel you know i i
think uh
we've seen time and time again how
similar
johnny and daniel are but at the same
time just how
it feels like you know oil and water the
two
kind of don't really mix well together
but
i will say i think they have a lot they
can learn from each other i think you
know
johnny has a lot of great life lessons
and daniel has the same and as long as i
think they
keep their arms distance they can they
can work together but
but i think once one of them steps over
that line it's going to be back to
square one just like we've seen you know
in seasons one and season two